What's going to happen
is robots will be able to do
everything better than us.
I mean, all of us, you know.
I'm not sure exactly
what to do about this.
Tech billionaire, Elon Musk
isn't the only one freaking out
over our new robot overlords.
Fears of automation
induced mass unemployment
are at the center of a push
for a universal basic income
or UBI in which the
government sends everyone
a monthly check, regardless of wealth.
Though the idea has been
kicking around for centuries,
it really caught fire recently
because of Andrew Yang
who ran for the Democratic
Presidential Nomination in 2020,
and to be mayor of New York in 2021.
His new memoir and political
party both called "Forward"
put UBI at the center of his agenda.
Last year, polls showed a
majority favoring the idea,
and cities like Los Angeles,
Saint Paul, Atlanta,
and Newark are experimenting
with or considering local UBIs.
Yang says cash payments are
better than government programs
for the same reason
that the libertarian
economist, Milton Friedman,
advocated slashing social welfare
in favor of direct subsidies to the poor
because it's more effective
to put unrestricted cash,
directly in the hands
of those who need it.
This is one thing that I believe
I'm fundamentally aligned
with libertarians on.
It's like I think people know best
how to solve their own
problems and what they need.
Than a government program,
I think that a lot of these bureaucracies
are very inefficient.
They're also somewhat punitive
where I talked to people
who are subject to them
and they live in fear
and anxiety all the time
that they're going to
fill out a form wrong
or miss an interview,
and then have it taken away from them.
I really like Andrew Yang's disposition,
his refusal to engage in the
dumbest cultural war skirmishes
and his willingness to call
out Republicans and Democrats.
But I think he's wrong to claim
that a UBI wouldn't do massive damage
to American labor markets and
the federal balance sheet.
During the pandemic, the
government shelled out
for three rounds of stimulus checks
to about 90% of households,
including sending money to the well-to-do
and it supplemented unemployment benefits
by as much as $600 a week.
One of the negatives of
this time in my mind, Nick,
is that we're tying so much
of the money to not working.
You know, like I talked to
a 25 year old young person
who is getting 500-600 bucks a week
and he said like, "look, I'm
not going to look for a job
until this trading runs out."
Yang says that an advantage of a UBI
is that it's not tied
to employment status.
But I think giving
people money for nothing
would make them less likely to show up
for a hard day's work.
The number of job openings
in the United States
has reached historic highs
even as the labor force
participation rate,
the percentage of working age
adults who either have jobs
or are looking for work
is almost two points lower
than before the pandemic began.
Here's another problem with the UBI,
why should middle-class Americans,
not to mention millionaires
and billionaires,
get a check from the government
just for being alive?
Making it universal has many benefits.
It reduces any stigma,
it makes it a true right of citizenship,
it gets rid of all of the
administration and game-playing,
no one's going to be
having to misrepresent
what their financial circumstances are.
I'm not a big fan of a
lot of the means testings
because of both the administration
and the game playing that goes on.
We miss a lot of people every
time we try and draw lines.
Maybe Yang is right that
giving everyone a check
would make the program
easier to administer.
But does billionaire Elon Musk really need
even more taxpayer money
than he's already raking in?
Such largess is
particularly hard to defend
given that the federal budget
has cracked $6 trillion
in each of the past two years,
and the national debt is
approaching $30 trillion.
When he was running for president,
Yang said the costs of giving
every American citizen,
a monthly check would be
partly covered by phasing out
certain amounts of existing spending.
Something that virtually never happens.
And even sympathetic
analysis of his plan noted
that its costs would soak up
all existing federal tax revenues
resulting in either massive deficits,
or humongous new tax hikes.
Senator Warren,
I've been talking to
Americans around the country
about automation and they're smart.
They see what's happening around them.
Their main street stores are closing.
They see a self-serve
kiosk in every McDonald's,
every grocery store, every CVS.
In fact, historically
game-changing innovations
haven't reduced the total number of jobs.
For all the talk about
the sudden disruptive loss
of good paying industrial jobs,
the fact is that manufacturing
peaked at around 40%
of all employment in 1943, since then,
it's been a steady uninterrupted
decline over decades.
And yet there's been no
shortage of work opportunities
in new industries.
Driving a truck is the most
common job in 29 states,
including this one.
Three and a half million
truck drivers in this country,
and my friends in California
are piloting self-driving trucks.
Self driving cars,
displacing truck drivers
and delivery men are likely decades away.
And those productivity gains
will one day enable entrepreneurs
to create whole new industries
with work opportunities not yet conceived.
Even in industries directly
impacted by automation,
the result is often more
jobs rather than fewer.
There are some structural
issues with our economy,
where a lot of businesses
have learned to become
much more efficient,
with a lot fewer workers.
You see it when you go to
a bank and you use an ATM,
you don't go to a bank teller.
Obama's analysis is wrong.
After banks rolled at ATM's in the 1990s,
the number of bank tellers
increased in the ensuing decades.
And in the years after supermarkets
and retailers introduced barcode scanning,
the number of cashiers
increased by more than 50%.
Andrew Yang's UBI
isn't going to be implemented
anywhere anytime soon,
but enhanced unemployment
benefits are going away.
So we'll soon find out
whether getting less money
from the government spurs more
people to go look for work.
If and when they do,
job seekers we'll find an economy
where employers are begging for help
and offering unprecedented
incentives from appetizers,
to signing bonuses, to free tuition,
to get people to start
punching a clock again.
That's not Andrew Yang's way forward,
but it has the benefit of
reducing dependency on the state
re-energizing the labor market
and not making the
government even more broke,
than it already is.